>> Greg: THE REPUBLICANS WON
BACK THE SENATE WHERE THEY
APPOINT JUDGES.
DEMS TOOK THE HOUSE WITH A FIXED
PARKING TICKETS.
THE REAL CHUMS ARE THOSE WHO
REJECTED DUE PROCESS.
REPUBLICANS UNSEATED FOUR
SENATORS.
HEITKAMP, McCASKILL, DONNELLY,
BILL NELSON.
ALL KNOWN FOR LEADING THE MOB
AND TRYING TO DO DESTROY JUSTICE
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
>> I WANTED TO HEAR DIRECTLY
FROM ME ABOUT WHY AM VOTING
AGAINST CONFIRMATION OF JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
>> I THINK THE VOTE AGAINST
KEVIN I WAS GOING TO BE TOUGH NO
MATTER WHAT.
>> I VOTED AGAINST JUDGE
KAVANAUGH BECAUSE OF CONCERNS
ABOUT HIS IMPARTIALITY.
>> I WILL VOTE NO ON JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
>> Greg: FOUR OUT OF THE SIX
VULNERABLE SENATE DEMOCRATS
LOST.
JON TESTER BARELY SQUEAKED IT
OUT.
THE ONE WHO REFUSED THE BAIT AND
VOTED FOR KAVANAUGH, JOE
MANCHIN.
HE WON.
IT SHOWS MANY AMERICANS WHICH
TRIAL UNFOLD BEFORE THEIR VERY
EYES AND THEY DIDN'T SHRUG IT
OFF.
IT'S TRUE THAT THE TWO BIGGEST
MONSTERS FEINSTEIN AND MAZIE DID
FINE BUT FOR THE REST OF
CURRENTLY ACTIONS HAVE
CONSEQUENCES.
FOUR PEOPLE LOST THEIR JOBS.
MAYBE NEXT TIME THEY'RE ASKED TO
PLAY FAIR, DEMOCRATS MIGHT FEAR
FOR THEIR CAREERS BEFORE
DESTROYING ANOTHER'S.
IT WILL BE NICE IF THEY DIDN'T
RESORT TO SUCH HORRIBLE TACTICS
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE,
BUT THEIR POLITICIANS.
ON THE EVOLUTIONARY TRIBAL
PEOPLE WE ADMIRE, YOU WILL FIND
NURSES AT THE TOP AND
POLITICIANS AT THE BOTTOM.
THEY DO WHAT THEY DO A LOT OF
DESIRE FOR POWER.
THEY CAN UNDERSTAND RIGHT AND
WRONG, YOU THEY WILL UNDERSTAND
LIVING THERE CRAP OUT INBOXES.
DO
YOU THINK IT HAD AN EFFECT?
>> Dana: McCASKILL DECLARED
SHE WOULD VOTE AGAINST KAVANAUGH
BEFORE THE DOCTOR FORWARD
ALLEGATIONS CAME FORWARD.
SHE DIDN'T EVEN GIVE THEM A
CHANCE ON THAT.
I FEEL LIKE CHUCK SCHUMER MADE A
MISTAKE.
I SAID WHY DON'T THE DEMOCRATS
CAVE EARLY BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO
GET CONFIRMED.
INSTEAD OF DRAGGING IT OUT, JUST
LEFT THE RED STATE DEMOCRATS
VOTE FOR KAVANAUGH AND MOVE ON
AND FOCUS ON HEALTH CARE OR
WHATEVER.
INSTEAD THEY HAD TO HAVE THIS
MOMENT AND IT BACKFIRED.
>> Jesse: I CAN'T BELIEVE THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T TAKE POLITICAL
ADVICE FROM FOX NEWS.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THEY WOULD
REALLY LISTEN.
THE QUESTION IS, YOU ARE RIGHT,
THEY MADE A MISTAKE.
ARE THEY GOING TO REPEAT THE
SAME MISTAKE?
I THINK THEY PROBABLY WILL.
I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT HOW BAD THE POLLS
FOUR.
NBC NEWS, THEY WERE EIGHT POINTS
OFF IN INDIANA.
NINE POINTS OFF IN MISSOURI.
SEVEN POINTS OFF IN ARIZONA AND
I COULD GO DOWN THE LIST.
THE WORST POLL I'VE EVER SEEN IN
THE MIDTERM ELECTION IN THESE
RACES.
I COULD GO ON AND ON.
LOOK AT THE APPROVAL NUMBERS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN CRUCIAL
STATES.
MICHIGAN, 45.
PENNSYLVANIA, 45.
WISCONSIN, 47.
FLORIDA, 51%.
OHIO, 52%.
THOSE ARE REALLY GOOD APPROVAL
RATING NUMBERS GOING INTO 2020
AND LEAVE PEOPLE THINK THIS WAS
A BLUE WAVE, THIS WAS NOTHING.
>> Juan: OH, STOP.
WHO WON THE GOVERNOR'S RACE IN
WISCONSIN?
>> Jesse: PURPLE RAIN.
>> Juan: GOING BACK TO THE
POLL NUMBERS, I AM LOOKING AT
POLL NUMBERS ON KAVANAUGH.
THE VOTE ON KAVANAUGH, VERY
IMPORTANT.
42% OF REPUBLICANS THAT IT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT BUT 55% OF THE
DEMOCRATS SAY IT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THEM.
>> Greg: THEY HATE DUE
PROCESS.
>> Juan: THEY GAVE THE GUY DUE
YOU KNOW WHO DIDN'T GET DUE
PROCESS?
MERRICK GARLAND.
>> Greg: HE DIDN'T GET HIS
LIFE RUINED.
MERRICK GARLAND IS A MURDERER TO
THE DEMOCRATS.
HE DIDN'T.
HIS FAMILY IN FRONT ABOUT --
>> Juan: HE DIDN'T GET A
HEARING.
MITCH MCCONNELL PLAYED BRUTAL
POLITICS.
>> Martha: JOE MANCHIN, IN THE
POLLS BEFORE THE ELECTION, THEY
SAID WOULD YOU VOTE FOR HIM IF
HE HAD VOTED NO ON KAVANAUGH?
PEOPLE SAID NO, I WOULDN'T.
THE POLLS HAVE BEEN ALL OVER THE
PLACE ON KAVANAUGH BECAUSE SOME
OF THE ONCE WE GOT YESTERDAY
ALSO INDICATED THAT THAT WAS
MORE POSITIVE FOR DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, BUT THAT'S NOT
ALWAYS ALL PLAY OUT WITH
DONNELLY EITHER.
DONNELLY SAID IT HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE WHOLE DOCTOR FORWARD
THING.
IT'S BECAUSE HE'S IMPARTIAL.
DEMOCRATS WERE ALL OVER THE MAP.
IT OUTRAGE SO MANY PEOPLE IN
TERMS OF THE ISSUE OF WANTING A
FAIR PROCESS.
THAT'S WHAT IT REALLY GOT BACK
TO I THINK FOR SOME OF THE
PEOPLE.
WE THAT'S SUCH AN OLD DELEGATION
WITHOUT ENOUGH CORROBORATION AND
THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO SEE
SOMEONE BE HURT FOR THAT BECAUSE
IT'S NOT PROVABLE AT THAT POINT